well an historic day in American history
yesterday the January 6th Committee of
the House of Representatives
investigating the Trump Riots of 2021
has approved criminal referrals for a
former president no it's not against
Barack Obama Obama
and guys it's against failed former
president Donald Trump NBC news reports
January 6 committee approves criminal
referrals against Trump for his role in
trying to overturn the 2020 election the
panel also issued a criminal referral to
the doj for conservative Attorney John
Eastman he's the uh genius who came up
with the uh strategy I don't even know
what to call it the idea for how former
vice president Mike Pence could prevent
the certification of the 2020 election
we are going to now hear from one of the
members of the committee Jamie Raskin
let's listen the first criminal statute
we invoke for referral therefore is
Title 18 section 1512 C which makes it
unlawful for anyone to corruptly
obstruct
influence or impede
any official proceeding of the United
States government
we believe that the evidence described
by my colleagues today and assembled
throughout our hearings warrants a
criminal referral of former president
Donald J Trump John Eastman and others
for violations of this statute wow the
whole purpose and obvious effect of
Trump's scheme were to obstruct
influence and impede this official
proceeding the central moment for the
lawful transfer of power in the United
States
second
we believe that there is more than
sufficient evidence to refer former
president Donald J Trump John Eastman
and others for violating Title 18
section 371. this statute makes it a
crime to conspire to defraud the United
States
in other words to make an agreement to
impair obstruct or defeat the lawful
functions of the United States
government by deceitful or dishonest
means
former president Trump did not engage in
a plan to defraud the United States
acting alone he entered into agreements
formal and informal with several other
individuals who assisted him with his
criminal objectives I'll say our report
describes in detail the actions of
numerous co-conspirators who agreed with
and participated in Trump's plan to
impair obstruct and defeat the
certification of President Biden's
electoral victory
that said the subcommittee does not
attempt to determine all of the
potential participants in this
conspiracy as our understanding of the
role of many individuals may be
incomplete even today because they
refuse to answer our questions we trust
that the Department of Justice will be
able to form a far more complete picture
through its own investigation
third we make a referral based on Title
18 section 1001 which makes it unlawful
to knowingly and willfully make
materially false statements to the
federal government
just in the interest of time that this
was a very long hearing fourth is
inciting assisting or aiding slash
comforting and Insurrection so four
different criminal referrals how did
Trump react you could probably guess but
we're going to look at that a little
later but let me address some of the
emails that I've received about this
this is a long overdue step
but that's all it is it is one small
step and there's a lot of doubt and
cynicism in the emails that I've been
receiving from many of you over the last
24 hours and I get it I do get it we all
want to see Justice served against these
individuals but it is a process and it's
worth remembering that the doj
has to build the case there is an
astounding amount of evidence they have
to piece that case together and we all
know colloquially and folks everyone is
innocent until proven guilty in a court
of law this show is not a court of law
this is a place where we just speak
frankly we all know as we read through
the different uh statutes that Jamie
Raskin uh described there we all know
Trump did the stuff he's accused of we
all know that colloquially speaking he
did it but the question starts to become
is there the possibility of finding
guilt Beyond A Reasonable Doubt here we
all know and we watched enough to know
that colloquially speaking of course
Donald Trump did the things for which he
is being referred and this includes all
four of those items that Jamie Raskin
mentioned he was able to incite a mob to
storm the capital on January 6th and
attempt to disrupt the peaceful
transition of power and put the lives of
members of Congress and his own vice
president at risk all of it all of it
all of it there are some who will argue
that the criminal referrals that we are
seeing here are strictly a political
move these aren't really law enforcement
elements this is just Democrats playing
politics and it may end up being that if
it doesn't go any further but this is a
necessary step in other words the
committee did what it had to do and it
determined we have the evidence for a
criminal referral it may stop there but
that's all that the the house committee
can actually do now it is a question of
what is Merrick Garland willing to do as
we spoke about yesterday and we talked
about the one word that is the reason
why presidents have not been indicted in
the United States that word is tradition
and that's not a very strong reason not
to indict a president who did things no
other president has done
how could Federal criminal charges
affect Trump's 2024 presidential run
becomes another political question as we
wait for answers to the legal questions
in general
in like a normal World criminal charges
against an individual while they're
running for president would affect their
reputation it would affect their
credibility it would make it more
difficult for them to actually win but
we've already experienced with Donald
Trump in 2016 that seemingly nothing can
actually damage him enough
with the Republican base to torpedo his
presidential campaign 2024 could be
different if Trump were to be convicted
of a crime now we're facing many uh
we're taking many hypothetical steps
into the future he could face prison
time yeah that would make it difficult
to hold office that would make it
difficult to campaign even if he was not
convicted or imprisoned the fact that he
would face criminal charges could be a
liability in a presidential campaign to
the extent that it becomes a distraction
it could raise questions about his
judgment or Fitness for office in a
normal world
but this is the Republican electorate
this is the very same Republican
electorate who chose him in 2016 and who
gleefully welcomed him back in 2020 as
their nominee so any assumption that
even criminal charges or a conviction
would torpedo Trump's campaign are
possible but potentially premature until
we actually see what happens let's now
talk about Donald Trump's reaction to
this
as many of you know I am fascinated by
cons and scams and multi-level marketing
and all this different stuff I recently
saw Inside the Mind of a con artist on
curiosity stream it's six episodes and
it was excellent I don't think I would
have discovered it were it not for our
sponsor curiosity stream curiosity
stream has all the newest and best
documentary films they've got the big
titles from the well-known filmmakers
they've got valuable Independent films
tons of original content that you can't
find anywhere else when I'm at home
browsing my different streaming
platforms I find curiosity stream to
really have the best selection of
documentaries specifically because
documentaries is all that they have and
they're always adding new titles my
audience gets access to curiosity
streams entire library of documentaries
for just 15 bucks a year that's 25
percent off go to to curiositystream.com
Pacman or use the code Pacman the link
is down below